Czym więc jest Qiskit?
Qiskit to zestaw narzędzi programistycznych open source
do pracy z komputerami kwantowymi
na poziomie circuit
algorytmów i modułów aplikacyjnych. Ten SDK
pozwala każdemu programować na prawdziwych komputerach kwantowych
z własnego laptopa. W dwóch linijkach kodu możesz uzyskać dostęp
do kilku systemów kwantowych, od nadprzewodzących
po qubit z pułapkami jonowymi. Chcesz emulować zachowanie komputera kwantowego?
Zmień jedną linijkę kodu
i symuluj swoje quantum circuit na naszym wysokowydajnym
symulatorze. Qiskit to narzędzie używane przez dziesiątki
tysięcy ludzi na całym świecie, próbujących
budować przyszłość. Niezależnie czy jesteś badaczem, deweloperem
czy dopiero zaczynasz swoją przygodę,
Qiskit oferuje szereg
funkcji dostępnych zgodnie z twoimi potrzebami,
pozwalając każdemu robić takie rzeczy
jak budowanie swojego pierwszego quantum circuit,
uruchamianie wielodziedzinowych algorytmów kwantowych
i badanie fundamentalnych zjawisk kwantowych.
Może teraz jest idealny moment, żeby samemu się zaangażować
i znaleźć wszystkie potrzebne narzędzia,
w tym prawdziwe komputery kwantowe
i SDK, przez Qiskit,
oraz społeczność, która chętnie powituje
i odpowie na każde pytanie, jakie możesz mieć po drodze.
Możesz zacząć już dziś
na qiskit.org